I told myself I wouldn't cry did
beautiful mountain a so while
oh god no matter for night for night
like oh how do I get victory riles how
do I do this how do I do this build
strategy whatever and then to the Great
Depression came I was in a really really
like sad state full of about for
probably like three to four months where
like every single day like you ever
gotten one of those days where like you
didn't want to hit the live button and
you kind of just look at it there's like
three to four months where I felt that
like every single day before I went live
it's like registered as I start saying
it and I started doing the voice as
there's lemon apart easily all the
meemers come to my chest all the BDD
peers frankerz e he motors got a match
at is swarming dude made it beyond the
mods and I guess all baby we got the
meaning Jets in the Dead Boys excited to
judge on stab you really want to drop in
it's happening drops
[Music]
they not paint we'll never be able to
come back you will never be able to make
it
he will never beat a 20 30 40 K and II
like it used to be
stay set give up it quit streaming stop
it throw it all the way dude you'll
never make it back but here we are
rise the [ __ ] up balance poppin off on
Twitch the game jumped to the top of the
streaming world with viewers flooding
select channels hoping they get access
to the closed beta and one of those
streamers is none other than TSM zone
[Music]
[ __ ] Usain Bolt
myths channel has become one of the
go-to destinations for valor and content
alongside the likes of summit and xqc
ladies and gentlemen boys and girls
stepping into the ring the Canadian
Gaylord
[Music]
The Dude's been averaging a view count
of 53,000 with one of his streams
peeking at over a hundred and twenty-two
thousand concurrent viewers many of them
hoping to get access to that closed beta
[Music]
for almost every other streamer this is
a once-in-a-lifetime opportunity but not
for myth C he found himself in a similar
situation a few years ago just with the
Battle Royale instead of a tactical
shooter you guys want to see the best
RPG snipe of all time
[Music]
myth was killing it on twitch with
fortnight he was considered one of the
game's first great builders earning
himself the nickname the young architect
he was the go-to if he wanted to watch
high level gameplay and his numbers
reflected them the dude was regularly
pulling in 50,000 viewers in 2018 with
some of his streams even peaking at over
a hundred K that's always up by what it
cried so wild it honestly is I don't
know I fell in love with his platform a
while ago
and I'm just like it says this is
amazing being able to make it this far
at the time that I have to have so much
respect for the people that have put in
the time and have been able to make like
allow me to do it I do you know like
ninja myth was a poster boy for the game
but unlike ninja he couldn't sustain his
bananas viewership community starting
off was like oh you know people
wondering how I'm you know asking a lot
of questions about the game right for
night for night like oh how do I get rid
three Royals how do I do this how I do
this build strategy whatever and then
the Great Depression came and then
people are just like [ __ ] [ __ ] on
me whatever talking [ __ ] model blah blah
blah I declined myths viewership
steadily declined dropping to an average
of 5,000 viewers a decline he blames on
himself the who I was I think I had an
ego pretty much so I didn't have the
right approach to streaming to that big
of an audience I didn't know how to
manage it I don't know exactly what to
do with it then after that competitively
I just didn't perform like at all this
took a toll on him some days he even had
trouble going live I was in a really
really like sad state full of about for
probably like 3 to 4 months where like
every single day like you ever gotten
one of those days we're like you didn't
want to hit the live button and you kind
of just look at it a little bit before
you just sit in your chair
kind of kind of people sad and you look
at it there's like three to four months
where I felt that like every single day
before I went live and most of it was
because like I don't want to deal with
the chat like there is just no
interaction with my chat my entire chat
was basically just like them [ __ ]
talking me every sick like every single
line in chat was somebody talking [ __ ]
so myth rebuilt his community thanks in
part to his uncanny impression of a
certain québécois streamer well thanks
for the gifts average a lot and I what's
the other time take it easy enjoy your
okay boys good one that was good that
was good
myths impressions alongside a new more
relaxed attitude towards streaming
broaden to viewers from execute see and
other streaming communities and with
these new viewers myth cultivated a new
dank audience
it's like residence as I think that and
I started doing the voice as I was lemon
of Arts is Lee all the meemers come to
my chest BTT viewers frankerz II a
motors got a match at is swarming did
made of you in the mods and I guess I'll
baby we got the meaning jet than the
Dead Boys but Fowler n't has been a
whole new beast he's getting viewership
that rivals his old fortnight days now
he's sitting at the top of the twitch
charts giving a giant middle finger to
all those people who said his career was
dead I don't have much the same besides
a great thank you but I say we go onward
we keep reaching and striving for bigger
better things because guess what dude
when we fell off and took that massive
Hinnom viewership during fortnight dude
they thought hey myth we'll never be
able to come back he will never be able
to make it he will never be a 20-30-40
K&E like he used to be stay dead give up
mitt quit streaming stop it throw it all
away dude you
never make it back but here we are
Memphis back to being one of the most
watched streamers on Twitch thanks in
part to valance and that would be you do
that as saw to get a execute data oh my
god horny but it's one thing for him to
get a bunch of new viewers converting
those eyeballs into members of his new
meme filled community is the real
challenge thanks for watching if you
want more content like this hit the sub
button and ring that notification bell
for unique bite-sized videos you will
find anywhere else hit up our Instagram
Twitter and Facebook pages